in dortmund soll am freitag ein 23 jahre
alter mann eine 13 jährige vergewaltigt
haben
jetzt kommt raus er hatte vor einem
monat bereits eine 11 jährige
vergewaltigt dirk dekker ist mir jetzt
live aus dortmund zugeschaltet guten
morgen du kannst uns den ganzen fall
noch einmal schildern ja am freitag um
17 uhr 45 hat wohl in der dortmunder
nordstadt in einem hausflur diese
schreckliche tat stattgefunden
ein afghane der hier ein vorläufiges
bleiberecht hat hans wurde ein junges
mädchen 13 jahre alt in einen hausflur
gelockt und dort sexuell missbraucht und
vergewaltigt
genau dieser täter hatte gut einen monat
vorher zwanzigsten juni bereits schon
einmal eine derartige tat verübt wo er
einen zur tatzeit elfjähriges mädchen
wohl auch schon vergewaltigt und sexuell
missbraucht hat die staatsanwaltschaft
selbstbild sich zu der ersten tat noch
in schweigen bestätigt den fall aber und
spricht von einem vergleichbaren fall
nach der ersten tat ist der täter wohl
offenbar wieder auf freien fuß gekommen
nachdem er kurzfristig etwa zwölf tage
in u-haft saß mit der begründung es
bestehe kein haftgrund daher einen
festen wohnsitz hat also er wohnt wohl
in einer wohnung auch in der dortmunder
nordstadt und nicht in einem
asylbewerberheim oder einer unterkunft
da dankeschön dirk decker für deine
ersten information wir bleiben natürlich
weiter an diesen unglaublichen fall dran
vielen dank nach dortmund